[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver ce
soir on va s'intéresser au couple
franco-allemand le chancelier Olaf
Scholl c'était à Paris aujourd'hui pour
un déjeuner avec Emmanuel Macron à
l'Élysée report historique du Conseil
des ministres franco-allemand différents
stratégiques sur les questions
énergétiques et de défense la tension
reste vive entre les deux pays alors ce
tête à tête organisé en catastrophe
a-t-il permis d'aplanir les désaccords
peut-on parler d'une crise entre la
France et l'Allemagne grand débat dans
un instant avec nos invités sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin ce soir nous
régale une fois encore avec un nouveau
tome de son histoire intime de la 5ème
République les années 70 la décennie
prodigieuse celle de l'insouciance et du
plein emploi celle de son entrée en
journalisme aussi sous Pompidou jusqu'à
Mitterrand la belle époque et publié
chez Gallimard et comme d'habitude c'est
jubilatoire Franz Olivier Gilbert va
passer l'heure avec nous enfin trois
affranchis trois ce soir le système D
des députés enceintes c'est l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée signée Marco
pommier le scandale des placardisés on
verra ça avec Fanny guinochet et puis le
regard d'Isabelle Lasserre sur les
premiers à votre faiblesse de Vladimir
Poutine sur les tas de son armée voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
bonsoir Franck Olivier et merci d'être
fidèle à cette émission on est ravi de
vous accueillir pour ce nouvel opus de
vos mémoires c'est un peu vos mémoires
quand même cette histoire intime de la
Cinquième République ça s'appelle la
Belle Époque chez Gallimard vous
racontez tambour battant les années 70
ou la France je vous cite était comme un
bolide lancé à pleine vitesse vous
raconter aussi votre jeunesse à la
conquête de Paris et celle de ce beau
métier que nous exerçons le journalisme
vous racontez bien sûr les présidents
que vous connaissez si bien la société
la musique les chansons le cinéma on va
en parler longuement vous raconter aussi
au creux cette époque la nôtre que vous
aimez beaucoup beaucoup moins on a du
temps pour en parler justement
la plume pour défaire j'ai peut-être
l'âge d'un vieux con mais je crois que
je suis pas encore tout à fait dans la
catégorie on garde pour tout à l'heure
deuxième partie on commence avec l'image
du jour et cette poignée de main pour
donner le change après la brouille
affichée entre les deux rives du Rhin
vous le voyez Emmanuel Macron et Olaf
Scholl ça l'Elysée pour un déjeuner mais
pas un mot à la sortie sur ce début de
crise peut-être que le mot est exagéré
on le verra qui couvre entre Paris et
Berlin bonsoir Frédéric petit bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous êtes député MoDem
des Français établis notamment en
Allemagne et pas seulement Pologne et
également les les Balkans bonsoir Léo
clim merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste au Spiegel Richard werli que
vous connaissez bien pour ceux qui sont
fidèles à cette émission va nous
rejoindre dans un instant correspondant
France Europe pour le quotidien suisse
Blic le temps pour Stéphane blackovski
de nous planter le décor oh là là tirait
titre et Libération ce matin pour
décrire ces tensions si j'ai bien
compris la mi blackowski tout de suite
[Musique]
théorème de Boris Vian c'est quoi le
théorème de Boris
Vianney
et la France
on fait un peu de teasing faut attendre
avant de parler des années 70
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à tous
d'ailleurs bonsoir messieurs si j'ai
bien compris ce soir alors si j'ai rien
compris en ce moment on est un peu fâché
avec nos voisins allemands alors c'est
pas les grosses fâcheries du 20e siècle
mais c'est quand même un petit peu tendu
et la preuve vous venez de le dire
aucune conférence de presse n'a été
organisée à l'issue de la rencontre
entre Scholtz et Macron et l'Élysée donc
la dernière fois que le président Macron
n'a pas organisé de conférence de presse
après avoir reçu un chef d'État c'était
pour en tout cas leader c'était pour le
Premier ministre saoudien Mohamed Ben
Salman les Allemands ont des raisons de
mal le prendre c'est quand même un
affront qu'il aurait fait donc il y a
pas de parole du coup on est obligé
d'interpréter le langage corporel alors
regardez donc effectivement ça arrive oh
Mercedes donc ça jusque-là tout est
normal le président Macron sont les
quatre marches du perron ça c'est
toujours bon signe mais ils veulent
tirer vers le haut regardez hop allez
vite alors que Allah
il y a une question
là on fait demi-tour du coup comment va
je comprends quoi hop voilà viens voir
par ici et petit sourire crispé vous
voyez c'est pas un grand naturel non
plus cette qu'est-ce qui ne va pas entre
les deux pays en ce moment c'est
toujours la même chose vous le savez
tout le monde le sait j'imagine quand un
couple est en crise en fait on ne
supporte plus les défauts de son
partenaire or quel est le principal
défaut de l'Allemagne quelqu'un a une
idée mais c'est l'égoïsme bien sûr mais
bien sûr l'Egoïsme maintenant que les
Allemands mais évidemment vous savez
regardez ils avaient tout misé sur le
gaz rue Sésame maintenant qu'ils ont
s'en priver leur premier réflexe
regardez Olaf Scholl c'était une sorte
de tour du monde depuis quelques mois il
aurait là il est en Norvège mais il a
été au Canada il est au Sénégal sans
oublier bien sûr la petite tournée dans
les pays du Golf donc l'Allemagne
voulait absolument remplir ses cubes à
tout prix puisque la monnaie moyen alors
que elle aurait pu avoir un réflexe
européen et faire des achats groupés
comme ah bah c'est en train de changer
ça oui c'est vrai que l'Allemagne a fini
par valider au moins ce principe des
achats groupés je sais pas exactement
quel est l'auteur je crois que c'est 15%
mais
je vais quand même revenir sur l'égoïste
de mes allemands parce que ça leur
principal défaut regardez ils ont quand
même débloqué 200 milliards pour
soutenir une particulier mais aussi
l'industrie face à l'os du gaz vous
savez que les Allemands sont intrêtables
en Europe sur l'endettement ils ont même
la suspendu une clause qui normalement
leur interdit de trop s'endetter donc
forcément le président Macron bah il a
pas dit égoïste enfin il était un peu
fâché contre les Allemands à l'écoute
aujourd'hui quand même une très large
unité entre les pays donc je vais
travailler avec entre le chancelier je
pense que ce n'est pas bon ni pour
l'Allemagne ni pour l'Europe quel
s'isole et oui l'Allemagne s'isole mais
quand on fait ce genre de reproches aux
Allemands forcément ils ont une réponse
trop de trouver il pose une devinette il
dit mais quel est le pays qui contribue
le plus au fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne
on est le principal contributeur au sein
de l'Union européenne on paie 26% du
budget et on développe beaucoup de
mécanismes de solidarité
il y a un communiqué de presse un côté
français et un tweet d'ailleurs de la
chose côté allemand la rencontre
aujourd'hui a été constructive ah oui
mais attention c'est du langage
diplomatique ça a été constructive
constructif ou constructive la rencontre
ça veut dire qu'on s'est dit des choses
bien en phase donc j'imagine que le
président Macron a ressorti le graphique
qu'il avait montré l'émission avec
Caroline Roux vous voyez quand il
montrait où sont les centrales à charbon
en Europe donc comment l'Allemagne nous
empoisonne clairement avec ses mauvais
choix sur le gaz russe au lieu d'avoir
choisi le bon nucléaire français et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il a répondu au live
Scholtz il a sorti son badge j'imagine
atom craft mind donc et il a fait comme
son ministre de l'économie en disant
mais bon centrale nucléaire elle ne
marche même pas de quoi vous nous parlez
les Français donc évidemment c'est un
petit peu tendu alors c'est constructif
est-ce que c'est rassurant regardez la
dernière fois que byden et Poutine se
sont rencontrés c'est à Genève l'an
dernier
c'est merveilleux c'est une rencontre
constructive donc comment ça va se
passer je sais pas moi c'est un truc de
spécialiste là je et ben voilà le décor
est planté comme chaque sœur merci pour
ce billet Sté
phane trier sur cette tension actuelle
c'est quand même très rare qu'un conseil
des ministres franco-allemand
normalement c'est calibré orchestré soit
reporté oui oui c'est très rare je je le
reconnais moi je voudrais d'abord
expliquer que le il faut pas réduire le
franco-allemand au franco-allemand que
j'appelle gouvernemental et encore moins
au franco-allemand du haut de l'État le
franco-allemand s'étouffue si je vous
racontais ce que j'ai fait dans ces
dernières semaines j'ai fait le Congrès
des clubs d'affaires franco-allemand à
Aix j'ai fait on a relancé l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande suite aux
élections
on parle on parle de ces tensions et on
se parle et on se parle et on sait que
c'est difficile
voilà donc ce qui se passe évidemment il
y a des il y a des différents c'est
clair et on nous avons des différents
mais moi ce que je voudrais rappeler que
ce que je dis moi depuis le 25 février
depuis le 24 février en hémicycle
on va dire cette guerre nous concerne en
Europe nous concernant franco-allemand
et donc il est normal qu'on soit un peu
secoué que sa tangue et repousser parce
qu'il est repoussé le Conseil moi je
sais qu'il se prépare aussi dans des tas
de domaines parce qu'un conseil des
ministres c'est pas que les deux chefs
d'État c'est tous les ministres qui
préparent des choses agriculture
moi ce que je vois surtout
il vaut mieux aujourd'hui ils étaient là
pour remettre un certain nombre de
pendules à zéro ils prennent du temps ça
veut dire qu'ils vont retourner dans
leur dans leur service et essayer de
chercher il y a des choses qui ont
avancé on a avancé sur les points de
tension vous vous avez quelques infos
qui ont pu filtrer des deux côtés des
diplomaties côté allemand il y avait un
édit tôt ce matin sur France Inter signé
jean-marcourt très intéressant qui qui
disait qu'en allemand on dit pas couple
parce qu'on n'est pas marié on parle de
Tandem
les Français aiment bien relever que les
Allemands ont plus des références
évidemment mécaniques le moteur l'axe ça
ne ressemble plus peut-être c'est vrai
que tout ce qui peut avoir très à
l'amour ou au couple non mais plus
sérieusement oui ça c'est le vocabulaire
mais au-delà les Allemands sont très
attachés à la relation franco-allemande
et à l'Europe il y a peut-être ou pas
alors non non mais il y a une crise
effectivement et justement au sommet
justement politique alors le Conseil
franco-allemand d'ailleurs qui a été
reporté là maintenant il avait déjà été
reporté parce qu'il devait avoir lieu en
juillet au départ mais ça personne n'en
a parlé parce que son report n'a pas été
mis en scène le fracas l'affront n'a pas
été mise en scène
et ça c'est une une stratégie de tension
d'escalade choisi délibérément par
Emmanuel Macron parce que il en avait
marre de certaines choses qui qui
fonctionnaient mal ils se sentait pas
assez considéré pas assez
le tandem on peut aussi parler de Tandem
ne marchait pas bien donc il a mis un
point d'honneur à le montrer et je pense
qu'il a eu beaucoup de succès avec cette
stratégie parce qu'il a cornérisé au la
chose c'est qu'il a mis sous pression et
que maintenant
le chancelier allemand est sur la
défense donc tout ça et penser
orchestrer bon soirée bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
c'est
juste après Emmanuel Macron qui veut
plafonner les prix du gaz destiné à
produire de l'électricité ce Conseil
européen 27 a échoué là-dessus et en
même temps la photo aux Allemands ou pas
et en même temps le sujet n'est plus que
jamais au cœur de de l'agenda européen
c'est déjà ça ou au contraire on dit pas
merci à Olaf Scholl ce soir là j'arrive
juste de Bruxelles et je peux vous dire
que quand on pose la question à des
fonctionnaires européens qui suivent les
relations franco-allemandes le mot crise
est exactement ce qui convient et c'est
effectivement une crise personnelle
parce qu'il y a une incompréhension
peut-être caractérielle entre deux
personnages et Léo pour confirmer ou
infirmer Emmanuel Macron le joueur de
poker qui aime le risque en permanence
et Olaf schols qui déteste le risque
donc entre les deux c'est quand même
compliqué à rapprocher puis il y a une
autre réalité c'est que Olaf Scholl
c'est effectivement il a derrière lui
toute l'économie allemande qui demande
avant tout de la sécurité de la
visibilité notamment en matière
d’énergie il a choisi d'y répondre en
priorité et quand il voit Emmanuel
Macron parce que c'est quand même ça
derrière le projet de la France
aujourd'hui c'est quand même ce nouveau
plan de relance c'est à nouveau des
emprunts communautaires pardonnez-moi
l'expression mais c'est en gros on veut
que l'Allemagne pousse pour que l'Europe
fasse des chèques c'est quand même ça la
réalité et là on voit bien que ça coince
donc oui il y a ces difficultés mais je
voudrais juste dire une chose quand même
sur cette sur ce plafonnement l'argument
allemand il mérite quand même d'être
entendu les Allemands disent écoutés
nous Européens on est 500 millions
d'habitants ça pèse lourd sur le marché
mondial du gaz mais il faut pas rêver il
y a d'autres clients pour le gaz et
c'est pas parce que nous on décidera de
le plafonner que les vendeurs de gaz
l'Algérie l'Azerbaïdjan le Qatar
accepteront de le plafonner il a
peut-être pas tort ils ont peut-être pas
tort les Allemands qui viennent
peut-être de la société allemande qui
vise à dire un prétro bas du gaz nous
inciterait pas à changer de consommation
à faire de la sobriété c'est c'est
logique d'avoir ce genre d'argument là
ou c'est un peu
je sais pas là vous sous-entendez que
nous allemands aurions un penchant
naturel vers la sobriété et quelque part
le
enfin voilà ce passé de consommation non
s'il faut le rappeler oui absolument
alors eux sont très embêtés parce que
ils doivent accepter de faire marcher
des réacteurs nucléaires trois réacteurs
nucléaires plus un peu plus longtemps
que prévu
mais du point de vue non je pense qu'on
a une globalement une tradition de
politique économique un peu plus
libérale qui dit que il faut pas non
plus supprimer complètement le ce qu'on
appelle le signal prix parce que ça ça
aussi qui fait infléchir et changer les
comportements c'est voilà
comment vous regardez cette crise
puisqu'on a le droit d'utiliser le mot
c'est grave ou la France et l'Allemagne
en ont connu d'autres la France à
l'Allemagne beaucoup d'autres alors il y
a quelque chose qui s'est passé quand
même ces dernières années c'est que vous
savez c'est Gérard De Gaulle qui a
inventé ça hein faut jamais oublier en
1958 un week-end il a invité chez lui à
la boiserie conradaware c'était
extrêmement bien passé
les petits cadeaux ils se sont tellement
aimé que de Gaulle a fait une longue
série de fin de tournée en Allemagne il
a fait beaucoup de discours en allemand
enfin vous voyez c'était une époque oui
à peine 15 ans après la fin de la guerre
des retrouvailles extraordinaires et
après vous avez ces espèces de rapport
personnel en permanence entre les
responsables politiques enfin
mitterrancole c'était une amitié moi un
jour je me souviens j'arrive chez Cole
qui me parle de du temps du temps qui
faisait à Paris je dis comment comment
vous savez il me dit ben non je viens
d'avoir Mitterrand Mitterrand la pluie
il parlait du temps vous voyez vous
regardez les rapports Giscard Schmitt
etc et là c'est vrai que chose qui s'est
cassé mais c'est très important parce
que ça a été dit c'est que je pense que
ces deux sensibilités différentes
on voit que
il a pas un charisme considérable mais
il est très impressionnant c'est à dire
que il va vite moi ça m'impressionner
beaucoup ce qu'il a dit après la guerre
en Ukraine tout de suite aller on va
faire un plan de 100 milliards etc
c'est-à-dire il attend pas 5 minutes
enfin c'est un homme d'État quoi c'est
vraiment très impressionnant également
pour le le plan de relance à 200
milliards wooms là comme le bruit des
voitures qui démarrent c'est aussi très
très impressionnant parce qu'il va vite
et toute façon la situation je suis
désolé la situation de la France n'est
pas bonne mais ça fait très longtemps
qu'elle n'est pas bonne la situation de
l'Allemagne elle c'est nouveau que la
situation de l'Allemagne ne soit pas
bonne 900 milliards euh non pardon 900
millions de déficit du commerce
extérieur en mai dernier enfin c'est
c'est la fin du monde alors que
l'Allemagne jusqu'à présent c'était la
reine de l'excédent du commerce
extérieur alors que nous étions nous la
lanterne rouge donc si vous voulez il
sent toujours leur les moyens de leur
agenda c'est ce que sont égoïstes c'est
pas le cas c'est que voilà ils sont dans
une période de crise et ils veulent
ils veulent repartir un peu comme nous
on a fait le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
exactement la même histoire et de
l'autre côté on peut pas faire de
comment dire les les ceux qui nous ont
entraîné là parce que cette crise là on
cherche des responsables les bouc
émissaire de la crise alors cherche
Poutine on cherche non là il faut
arrêter et je pense que ils vont se
remettre ensemble à un moment donné mais
c'est un petit passage comme ça
l'énergie pour bien comprendre ce qui se
joue après avant de parler de la défense
Frédéric petit 200 milliards 200
milliards ça veut dire les Allemands qui
empruntent qui vont relancer leur
économie pour faire face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie sans les Européens
Thierry Breton dit on n'a pas été
consulté on sait même pas si c'est
compatible avec les règles sur les aides
d'État ils font quoi là les amis ce
sujet est à nouveau sur la table quand
même et ce que je voudrais dire par
rapport à ça c'est que effectivement moi
je crois beaucoup plus que
on parle de de caractère il faut aussi
parler de de situation exceptionnelles
en Allemagne ils sont chamboulé ce qui
s'est passé Scholl ça fait le Mark Ford
là ou quand vous dites ils ont été
obligés d'accepter les que les que les
Verts ont été obligés d'accepter ils ont
pas accepter c'est une je sais plus
comment vous appelez ça en allemand la
ligne rouge c'est c'est une décision
c'est un mot très compliqué à tiroir je
n'arrive pas à le traduire en français
je l'ai écouté en allemand mais il a dit
bah vous vous mettez pas d'accord c'est
dans ce cas-là moi j'ai le droit de
décider c'est une décision qui se prend
une fois tous les tous les 10 ans en
Allemagne donc c'est pas la coalition
qui décide qui avance donc je crois que
Scholtz et chamboulé il se passe des
choses qui ne sont pas l'habitude le
déficit on a parlé de déficit on parle
d'énergie c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
l'énergie parce que le problème de
l'énergie en Allemagne c'est que il faut
qu'il change le le dernier kilomètre de
l'énergie vous pouvez mettre toutes les
l'électricité que vous voulez en
Allemagne aujourd'hui à la place du gaz
vous chauffez personne et ça prend trois
ans de changer ça donc parce que ça
parce qu'on chauffe au gaz derrière ce
rapport de force je crois que
effectivement on voit ça se traduit par
l'histoire de personnes par des analyses
de photos c'est pas possible votre
prédécesseur qui le faisait tout à
l'heure mais évidemment mais je crois
aussi qu'il y a effectivement des et
c'est normal c'est c'est logique nous
avons des chefs d'État qui ont chacun
leur personnalité qui sont à mon avis
compatibles sur le fond mais qui sont
chamboulés par quelque chose
aussi derrière cette brouille la volonté
peut-être alors la complètement
implicite enfin je veux dire tu secrètes
etc mais en coulisses et bien de tenter
de convertir l'Allemagne au nucléaire
est-ce que c'est le tabou absolu
peut-être que ça marchera jamais mais
est-ce que les Français ne poussent pas
mais c'est pas du tout un non dit c'est
à dire que le vrai le vrai rêve de la
France ce serait que l'Allemagne reparte
dans le nucléaire parce que là la France
a des choses à offrir à la loi de la
France avait arrêté d'ailleurs le
nucléaire on sait pas pourquoi on aurait
des choses à offrir à l'Allemagne aurait
même cette idée ça je sais qu'il y a il
y a des scénarios qui ont été élaborés
pourquoi ne pas recréer autour du
nucléaire une forme de ce qui a été fait
autour du charbon et de l'acier il faut
quand même reconnaître que d'un point de
vue géopolitique ça élaboré ça aurait du
sens par le gouvernement
notamment à EDF on réfléchit à ce genre
de choses ça aurait du sens la
difficulté c'est quoi du sens pour nous
Français maintenant
pour l'Europe après tout après le
nucléaire est un débat d'un autre signe
mais d'un autre rang mais je veux dire
la difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui et
Léo le sait bien le parti qui pourrait
être sensible à ces arguments français
c'est la CD ou qui est dans l'opposition
d'ailleurs elle a regretté la Cedeo que
scholls récemment n'est pas parlé
davantage de la France dans son discours
de Prague donc là il a un problème pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est que la porte de
cette coalition la porte d'une claire
elle est fermée et quand même les
Français aimeraient bien le clim vu
d'Allemagne on parle d'homme d'État sur
ce plateau François Olivier Gilbert sur
la chasse mais est-ce qu'il est il est
contesté sa méthode est contestée il est
critiqué c'est très gentil à vous de lui
de lui donner ce titre d'homme d'État
déjà au bout d'un an après ça demande
est dur avec lui
et je pense que dans cette crise qu'il y
a actuellement entre la France et
l'Allemagne il y a oui il y a un
aspect de la personnalité de la chose
qui déjà avant était ministre des
Finances et déjà montré qu'il aimait
très peu écouté les autres il il ajoute
perso beaucoup et ça concerne pas que
l'accord avec la France il y a plein de
choses aussi dans la coalition
en ce qui concerne la question de la
livraison d'armes enfin c'est très très
compliqué et il a tendance à se
banqueriser dans sa chancellerie et
apprendre les décisions tout seul alors
c'est vrai qu'il est dans une
configuration politique compliquée mais
quand même moi je trouve que cette bien
sûr c'est c'est une crise qui peut
passer et elle peut être très productive
si la France et l'Allemagne maintenant
arrive à se mettre d'accord alors là ce
sera un grand coup de force qui peut
mener toute l'Europe et et mais c'est
bien ça qui est en jeu donc c'est très
inquiétant aussi oui donc c'est
inquiétant on va voir ce qui va là ce
qui va en être prochain Conseil européen
un mot encore et puis ensuite on passe à
la défense de l'énergie je crois que ce
qui est important c'est pareil de rêve
de de nucléaire en Allemagne etc ceux
qui se passe en ce moment et là où il y
a vraiment des des réflexions intenses
c'est plutôt à rtef c'est-à-dire de dire
nous n'avons pas nous avons un problème
aujourd'hui dans le réseau de transport
européen c'est ça le problème et
effectivement parce que l'Allemagne
utilise du nucléaire aujourd'hui il faut
et c'est très risqué quand ils ont du
vent et qui qui mettent le réseau
européen en black-out parce que ils ont
pas les fils qui vont bien chez eux
l'aménagement du réseau c'est
l'aménagement du réseau et là
effectivement parce que je vous rappelle
que les lampes viennent de cette N400
fois pendant que je parle là que le
réseau c'est un métier c'est un travail
nous l'avons séparé il y a 20 ans pour
des mauvaises raisons maintenant il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent le transport
en le transport de l'électricité en
Europe ça doit être géré ensemble à 1/50
de seconde et quand on aura fait ça
évidemment le nucléaire même l'Hydra
tout ça sera beaucoup plus balancé si on
a un réseau qui est homogène les copains
polonais qui travaillent dans ce domaine
là parce que le réseau polonais est
aussi un réseau intelligent disent on
économise à consommation égale on
économise 15%, je pense qu'ils exagèrent
parce que c'est le foisonnement et
effectivement à partir du moment où vous
faire de l'hydrogène du vert comme en
Allemagne il y a pas de problème que le
verre soit en Allemagne si on peut
communiquer à chaque 50e de seconde et
équilibrer nos réseaux alors autre pomme
de discorde je le disais la défense on
va le voir côté allemand c'est c'est
compliqué puisque la menace russe a
rendu le réarmement du pays extrêmement
urgent manifestement les industriels ne
veulent pas s'entendre entre Paris et
Berlin ce qui aurait poussé le
chancelier allemand à se tourner vers
les États-Unis pour passer des contrats
très très importants explications
en allemand on appelle cela side 22 pour
tournant tournant historique dans la
stratégie allemande en février 2022
quelques jours après le début de la
guerre entre la Russie et le crâne le
chancelier Olaf scholls prend la parole
au bout de stage d'abord le budget
fédéral 2022 dotera ce fond spécial d'un
montant unique de 100 milliards d'euros
il nous utiliserons ces fonds pour les
investissements et les projets
d'armement nécessaires
nous allons à partir de maintenant
d'année en année investir plus de 2% de
notre produit intérieur brut dans notre
défense
dans un consensus politique rare
l'Allemagne rompe avec sa tradition
antimilitariste
héritée de la deuxième guerre mondiale
100 milliards d'euros donc pour
moderniser une armée sous équipée au
début Paris voie d'un bon œil se
revirement espérant en faire bénéficier
son industrie mais rapidement les choix
stratégiques de l'Allemagne sont vécues
comme des camouflés de ce côté du rein
ainsi se tourne-t-elle vers les
États-Unis pour commander 35 avions de
combat F-35 dans le même temps le projet
commun européen d’avion du futur SCAF
est au point mort
l'Allemagne entend par ailleurs se doté
d'un bouclier antimissile et anti-aérien
en partenariat avec 14 autres pays une
initiative décriée par la France
Frédéric petit c'est une mauvaise
manière qui a fait l'Allemagne à la
France en passant commande aux
Américains d'abord je voudrais dire que
le side 22 de ce que moi je vois puisque
je suis le député qui représente ça
c'est pas c'est pas cholle ce qui dévale
qui débarque d'un coup c'est quelque
chose qui est venu de loin il y a des je
participe souvent depuis des années à
des chtifongs à des rencontres
le fait il va falloir que le revienne
c'est pas uniquement réarmé c'est que
l'Allemagne reprenne une responsabilité
sur le monde ce qu'elle refusait de
faire en gros nous on fait du business
sans ça vous pouvez traduire ça par le
changement d'époque changement d'époque
voilà changement d'époque mais c'est
quelque chose qui dans la jeunesse
allemande celle qui a voté
de manière très claire soit FDP soit
vert aux dernières élections cette
jeunesse allemande dans les dans les
chiffres tout dans les dans les dans là
où ils le disent depuis longtemps on
pourra pas faire 14% de business avec la
Chine et pas se poser de questions c'est
plus c'est plus ça notre Allemagne à
nous donc le tside 22 moi je le vois
plutôt comme le fait que il y avait des
vagues avec quelque chose qui avançait
et puis à un moment c'est obligé alors
provoquer par une crise mais c'est
obligé
les avions américains ils peuvent pas
faire autrement puisque c'est fait pour
porter des armes qui ont déjà acheté ça
et le Skaf il sera là dans dans 12 ans
le SCAP on est en train de le mettre en
place non on parle des avions les avions
voilà le Skaf il y a des problèmes j'ai
eu une réflexion d'un Allemand lors d'un
débat l'autre jour qui dit oui la
différence c'est que les Français quand
vous faites le SCAP vous êtes en vous
vous êtes en train de construire un
symbole de la souveraineté européenne
nous les Allemands ont fait un avion
voilà donc effectivement ça discute
beaucoup c'est en train de se régler
c'est en train de se régler il y avait
quand même un projet d'Europe de la
défense pas forcément des armées
communes mais ricardie
Berlin c'est dans 12 ans je crois qu'il
y a une vraie différence d'appréciation
sur le terme souvent utilisé par
Emmanuel Macron de souveraineté
européenne c'est à dire que pour les
Allemands pour les responsables
allemands il y a une nécessité d'une
souveraineté européenne voire d'une
défense européenne mais le matériel
qu'il peut le permettre maintenant n'est
pas nécessairement indisponible ou alors
il parler de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique et deux si on peut aussi
construire une souveraineté européenne à
base de matériel américain parce que
c'est une nouveauté européenne au sein
de l'OTAN et je crois que il y a tous
les éléments je dirais technique pour
l'achat d'un avion vous savez même la
Suisse pays ne racheter des F35 donc
vous voyez le F-35 en ce moment il se
vend bien partout mais parce que il y a
aussi une question de culture l'armée
allemande dont on a vu qu'elle était un
peu en mauvais état mais c'est une armée
complètement haute tanesse complètement
americanisée donc le réflexe naturel
c'est d'aller du côté du Pentagone
là-dessus je suis franchement aussi
commandé par d'autres pays européens au
sein des 27 les Pays-Bas donc ils ont
besoin aujourd'hui alors que l'avion
commun sera là dans 12 ans alors les F35
ça c'est les affirce et il y a aussi le
système anti-missiles le Skydome alors
ça c'est d'ailleurs c'est assez cocasse
quand on regarde à l'échelle de
l'histoire du 20e siècle les 21e siècle
c'est l'Allemagne qui commande à Israël
un bouclier anti-missiles pour se
défendre parce que visiblement il marche
bien donc
voilà c'est après que ça brusque les
Français
en Roumanie actuellement
franco-italien et évidemment alors je
comprends très très bien que Emmanuel
Macron est pris ça comme comme un
affronte
c'est la base c'est la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase là c'est pour ça que
qu'on est on a tout ce conflit
actuellement que qu'on a fait que
Emmanuel Macron a fait éclater crever la
PC quelque part c'est à cause de cette
histoire de bouclier pour les Allemands
vraiment c'est un c'est un changement
d'époque et c'est il faut bien voir que
c'est le pays au centre de l'Europe qui
est beaucoup plus bousculé par cette
guerre en Ukraine que la France parce
que c'est à différents niveaux il faut
revisiter effectivement le rapport qu'on
a à la défense à la guerre en général
donc ça c'est très compliqué pour des
raisons historiques et les questions
géographiques aussi pour des raisons
géographiques aussi on doit réviser
notre rapport aux échanges
internationaux donc le rôle en tant que
grande nation exportatrice et
l'énergie donc beaucoup de décisions
fondamentales qui doivent être qui
doivent changer d'un moment à l'autre
mais ça c'est assez douloureux et je
pense que les frictions qu'on voit avec
la France actuellement sont une
expression de cette voilà ce moment de
plus qu'un moment une période de
recherche d'un nouveau positionnement et
il s'est très important que la France
rappelle que ce positionnement doit être
européen alors fente Olivier Giesbert un
mot là-dessus on sent que il y a aussi
une Allemagne qui regarde vers l'est et
qui regarde vers la Pologne aussi qui
regarde encore plus à l'est vers la
Chine c'est l'agression de la Russie qui
a rendu l'Allemagne enfin d'abord les
difficultés économiques et puis ensuite
cette espèce de recherche parce que tout
ce qu'on vient de dire sur la défense
c'est vrai que on a du mal à être
rassuré c'est à dire que a priori le
choix comme ça de se lancer pour
l'Allemagne c'était formidable parce que
on a bien vu le côté pathétique de la
France avec Macron qui se démenait mais
combien de vues divisions voilà il y a
pas de défense européenne il y a
personne il s'en fout évidemment Poutine
et demain il peut recommencer il peut
recommencer dans les pays baltes ou ou
en Pologne ou ailleurs et puis donc ça
se rapproche de l'Allemagne donc c'est
vrai que il y a cette angoisse et là ce
qui est difficile à comprendre même si
on connaît l'argument sur les 35 mais ce
qui est difficile à comprendre quand
même c'est que il y a pas eu un petit
moment pour voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire parce que le vrai sujet c'est la
défense européenne et la défense
européenne a l'impression que même si on
sent qu'il faut une défense forte et ben
ils sont pas prêts encore les Allemands
vous voyez on cette défense elle est oui
c'est on parle de l'OTAN vous voyez mais
alors que c'est vrai que le côté
français je pense qu'il y a ça Macron
porte ça c'est à dire l'idée d'avoir une
défense vraiment une défense européenne
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait des Anglais
d'ailleurs parce que
n'oublions pas quand même le prix
politique Emmanuel Macron paye de sa
formule l'OTAN mort cérébrale l'OTAN
mort cérébrale c'est rester c'est
vendredi je voudrais qu'on dise un mot
pour conclure ce débat sur sur la Chine
et sur la question commerciale allemande
vis-à-vis des Chinois on sait que il y a
des millions de voitures allemandes
exportées vers la Chine ils ont besoin
d'ailleurs les Européens aussi des
minerais chinois pour les batteries pour
même pour les éoliennes et puis et puis
il y a ce groupe chinois qui arrive à
Hambourg dans le port d'Hambourg ça fait
beaucoup non quand même là oui je crois
que dans dans ce qu'on appelle le side
22 il y a le fait que voilà aujourd'hui
en Allemagne on débat pas de la relation
avec la France je rappelle quand même
que la Scholl ça a été plénipotentiaire
ça a été un porteur du franco-allemand
en Allemagne ça il a été responsable de
ça
institutionnellement pas avec l'âme il a
fait il a fait c'est lui qui a fait
franco-allemand de Hambourg donc je lui
suis très reconnaissant
au port de Hambourg c'est à dire un truc
capable de désigner le l'équipe de
direction et il y a eu une réflexion qui
est en train de se conclure je sais pas
j'ai pas écouté ce matin mais qui
devrait ne pas avoir si il investit on
lui interdit d'avoir plus que peu
d'arriver à 25 % c'est un débat énorme
et qui est un signe que on commence à se
poser des questions mais encore une fois
ces questions étaient posées rapidement
de la société
quand même de l'Allemagne sur cette
question de la vie
est dans cette veine et dans cette
tradition aussi politiques de son parti
le SPD qui est un qui est d'aller faire
le business avec la Chine comme on
faisait le business aussi avec la Russie
il y a assez peu d'états d'âme et
Emmanuel Macron a été d'ailleurs aussi
vexé qui ne soit pas embarqué dans le
prochain voyage que voilà Shotz va
entreprendre pour aller en Chine parce
que l'idée française était d'y aller en
tant que Français Allemand ensemble et à
la place que fait olafhot comme
d'habitude il en est une délégation de
patrons allemands merci beaucoup on va
s'arrêter là évidemment ce dossier n'est
pas terminé on y reviendra forcément
dans ces débats dans sa vous regarde
merci messieurs je vous regarde avec moi
évidemment Franz Olivier Giesbert m'a
parlé de cette belle époque nouveau tome
de cette histoire intime de la Cinquième
République chez Gallimard on y croise
Pompidou c'est dans les collèges de
Pataphysique il y a des théorèmes de
borisian il y a le théorème de la belle
époque qui dit que c'était la même
manière
générale c'est un théorème à n'importe
quelle époque il y a toujours quelqu'un
pour dire de mon temps c'était mieux je
crois qu'il exprime comme ça
où tout était possible on va d'abord
voir ça en images avec Marion Becker et
on en parle juste après merci à vous
si on vous invite Franz Olivier Giesbert
c'est pour la belle époque le deuxième
volume de votre histoire de la Cinquième
République qui auscule de l'âge d'or
révolu des années 70
année d'insouciance décès ni prodigieuse
France heureuse de ces années Pompidou
et Giscard quand votre vie ressemblait
un film de Claude sauté sur des airs de
Dalida
[Musique]
c'est un récit politique à la lumière de
vos archives personnelles vous qui avez
chroniqué pendant 40 ans la vie
politique
journaliste nouvelle observateur pendant
ces fameuses années vous en deviendrez
le directeur de la rédaction puis
directeur des rédactions du Figaro et du
point vous êtes l'auteur de nombreux
romans et de biographie best-seller
celle de François Mitterrand et de
Jacques Chirac cette belle époque sans
doute vos plus belles années c'est la
décennie pendant laquelle jeune
journaliste vous nouez une relation
personnelle avec les deux hommes à
François Mitterrand comme a Jacques
Chirac vous prédirez qu'il deviendront
Président vous comptez leur résistible
ascension avec François Mitterrand qui
réveille les braises mal éteintes du
Parti socialiste vous tissez des liens
qui ne se briseront jamais il est mon
Pygmalion je suis sa Galatée qu'il
sculpte à sa guise en attendant
qu'Aphrodite me donne vie vous narez
votre coup de foudre pour le personnage
de Jacques Chirac chez lui la part
animale prenait toute la place au perché
les narines à la fût prêt à avaler la
mer les poissons les bigorneaux il
altaient comme un chien galopait comme
un cheval copulait comme un lapin sans
frais comme un cochon tout lui faisait
ventres
c'est un personnage de roman parce qu'il
est très complexe il est très romanaise
qui vit dans un monde romanes votre
récit est teinté de nostalgie pour cette
époque bénie pour ce jeune journaliste
insolent d'opérette que vous étiez pour
cette soif de politique dans la société
et pour ces personnages qui vous
fascinent c'était mieux avant vous le
répétez inlassablement le monde nous
appartenait alors que s'est-il passé
depuis
Gisbert vous a échappé pour comprendre
nos années que vous détestez tant
c'est vrai j'espère que vous avez
succombé à cette phrase du cétait mieux
avant pourtant que vous détestez quand
vous l'entendez dans la bouche des
autres je peux pas dire je déteste
l'époque simplement il me battre j'ai
toujours été toute façon résistant
combattant de mouvement général je
combats évidemment je combats le wokis
mais je combat tout ça je compare la
bêtise je combat la haine aussi et donc
tout ça monte et c'est vrai que dans les
années 70 il y avait du gauchisme il y
avait la coderie l'incommensurable
connerie mais oui il fallait voir les
choses qu'on entendait avec tous ces
imbéciles d'intellectuels qui vous
disaient mais non c'est très bien ce
qu'ils font alors que on les il suffit
de pages du petit livre rouge de Mao
c'est tout
très très dur avec 68
perte de l'autorité délire maoïs délit
de réalité hystérie mémorielle il y a
rien à sauver dans ce mouvement étudiant
la révolution sexuelle mais enfin c'est
un peu arrêté après avec le sida et la
suite mais il y a eu un mouvement oui de
libération de parole sage le garde bien
entendu mais oui moi ce que même dans
cette époque si vous voulez la belle
époque c'est que tout était possible
c'était incroyable on trouvait du boulot
il suffit de d'aller voir ce qui
m'arrivait de faire de piges dans un
appareil Normandie et pour disons
arrondir mais enfin moi j'étais étudiant
il suffisait d'aller dans un café tiens
il y aurait pas du boulot et cetera
d'ailleurs oui de la gare je me souviens
mais c'était de la folie et puis pas de
chômage vous voyez et tout le monde a
envie de bosser c'est-à-dire il y avait
pas aussi la culture anti-travail
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un nombre
quand je parlais de la bêtise et de la
haine aujourd'hui et c'est c'est très
important et donc moi je me bats donc je
ne dis pas que c'était époque c'est
foutu etc c'est pas vrai j'ai envie de
me battre et puis alors dernier point
parce que vous avez montré les images
j'ai vraiment c'est ça aussi c'est de
l'époque c'était quand même une mission
de fou que tout le monde regarde
le plus de ces années on va voir
quelques images
mais c'est mer
du monde sort tout le monde est passé
par là Aragon normalement tous les
grands écrivains et c'était juste
magique j'ai découvert George j'ai
découvert plein de choses j'ai découvert
Georges dumes enfin des grands on parle
pas c'était c'était une icône c'est plus
possible une émission pareil aujourd'hui
je me demande pourquoi c'est plus
possible il y a quelque chose qui va pas
pour que ce soit pas possible hein parce
que bon il y avait pivot évidemment la
magie de pivot ce personnage qui jouait
français moyen c'est comme ça qu'il a
gagné c'est comme ça que tout le monde
allait voir parce qu'il y avait pas plu
clivant et d'une certaine oui plus
modeste d'une certaine manière que lui
donc les gens mais c'était merveilleux
c'était pas et moi bon il y avait aussi
parce que on en parle la chanson la
chanson qui était qui a complètement
Alain Bashung tout ça c'était non
vraiment c'est moi j'ai adoré cette
époque alors on le sent d'ailleurs
actuellement je disais je autant je me
laissais porter disons dans les années
70 autant aujourd'hui oui je mets un
casque et j'ai envie de me battre et de
dire des choses quelques quelques
phrases sur vos sur vos présidents alors
il y en a un Pompidou la clope au bec
vous l'avez vous l'avez croisé seulement
c'était tout début de journée
il s'est foutu de ma gueule d'ailleurs
je me trompe
visionnaire cultiver l'un des présidents
les moins narcissiques de la cinquième
avec Hollande et Chirac vous dites qu'il
a tout eu il ne lui a manqué que les
circonstances mais il s'en fiche il a
quelque chose d'américain une confiance
indéfectible dans l'avenir et dans le
modèle de société occidentale qui lui a
permis par son seul labeur de monter au
sommet ah oui c'est ça c'est une
histoire de méritocratie complètement
dingue c'est-à-dire c'est des paysans
des instituteurs et puis le type il va
devenir banquier chez Rothschild et
ensuite président de la République il
vient de il vient du fond de la France
complètement et garder ça et garder
c'est il gardait toujours ses vieux
copains et ça c'était le côté rustique
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs aussi qu'il
a été populaire très et qu'il y a même
toujours un peu une nostalgie Pompidou
même si on peut pas dire que il a été un
grand président parce que son mandat
était courté par la maladie il est mort
et d'ailleurs il était déjà malade comme
je révèle dans le livre quand il est
arrivé au pouvoir et c'est oui il avait
déjà son son cette affreuse maladie du
sang et qui qu'il a fait vraiment
souffrir énormément et bon on va dire
que c'est une grande page quoi
l'admiration est-ce que est-ce que c'est
Mitterrand quand même plus que Jacques
Chirac j'ai envie de répondre tout
simplement
moi je devais beaucoup à Mitterrand
comme jeune journaliste parce qu'il m'a
appris plein de choses il m'a pris la
vie Mitterrand c'était comme vous l'avez
montré dans la situation Pygmalion mais
c'est un Pygmalion donc vous apprenez
des choses
c'est quelqu'un qui veut donner des
bouquins vous devriez lire ça et puis
alors il faisait des choses aussi pour
la vie tiens euh vous quand vous avez
des amis il faut les voir toujours à
date fixe sinon vous allez voir dans
Hors porter dans le tourbillon de la vie
dans quatre cinq ans vous aurez perdu
vous ne le reverrez plus donc il y avait
un meilleur président si il avait gagné
en 74 il était plus clairvoyant on les
élit toujours trop tard d'ailleurs même
chose il aurait fallu avoir
Mitterrand en 74 et Chirac en 88 en
Chirac en 88 il avait de l'énergie et il
y avait comme quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir en 1995 c'était trop tard c'est
qu'il était triste il y avait une sorte
de mélancolie qui a marqué toute son
mandat oui parce que parce qu'il avait
été beaucoup travaillé d'ailleurs
c'était la suite de l'affaire maladie on
voyait que c'est quelqu'un qui croyait
plus rien qui croyait plus en personne
alors qu'en 88 il y avait il y avait une
belle énergie parce que Chirac je veux
dire aussi c'est quelqu'un que que
vraiment j'ai j'ai adoré suivi parce que
parce qu'il était tellement très
lentement vous allez en Corrèze euh vous
avez toutes les gens vous disais non
mais en Corrèze les petites vous disais
ah non mais je suis communiste
et je retire Chirac c'est une phrase que
j'ai entendu 50 fois en Corée c'est à
dire vous allez voir il s'est fait élire
dans une dans un du circonscription qui
était hyper à gauche je pige toujours de
Gaulle même il y en a fait un secrétaire
d'État de Gaulle même a demandé à le
voir parce que quand il a été élu en 67
il dit mais comment c'est possible ce
type qui était dans un dans un parce que
non il y avait l'empathie c'est-à-dire
une forme il aimait les gens et ça c'est
évidemment très important quand on fait
de la police sur le métier de
journaliste oui bien sûr c'est drôle
parce que au fond vous vous dites ce
métier là l'expression c'est que vous
vous l'étiez déjà dans le ventre de
votre mère vous avez ça dans le sang
vous êtes un curieux nez et en même
temps vous dites c'est génial on peut
raconter aux autres qu'on n'a jamais vu
leur expliquer ce qu'on va pas compris
vous l'avez adoré ce métier est-ce que
vous l'estimez profondément oui mais bon
simplement il y a plusieurs façons
d'exercer le journaliste il y a des gens
qui exercent journée d'une façon que je
trouve militante débile ou abject ça
dépend où il y a un trop grand cy
parfois puis surtout une sorte de
mélange militantisme un peu bêta-son on
l'a vu à l'occasion d'ailleurs des
dernières élections donc ça c'est vrai
que mais en même temps moi je voulais
être écrivain
aujourd'hui c'est très antidémique oui
bien sûr mais journaliste c'est très
antinomique et c'est vrai que je me suis
parce que peut-être j'étais très timide
je me suis guéri de pile vous avez
remarqué mais j'étais très timide
j'allais vers un métier
tous mes copains d'école souviens bien
je quand on m'appelait au tableau je
bredouillais je sais plus venir je sais
pas bon après j'ai essayé comme tous les
beaucoup timides d'ailleurs les avocats
vous regardez les avocats la plupart du
temps
qui ont décidé de sortir de même
effectivement et de se guérir de ça
alors c'est une époque
clamer à tue-tête qu'on était fier
d'être française vous y tenez
en France aujourd'hui on peut plus le
dire est-ce que vous êtes pas un peu
caricatural quand vous écrivez ça
sûr qu'on peut envahir à l'époque un
père avec une relation si difficile
conflictuelle vous l'avez beaucoup haï
ce père américain Ji venu en Normandie
débarqué
comme lui qui regrettait
l'américanisation de la société
française dans les années 70 et bien
vous vous dites qu'il devient suspect
d'aimer de célébrer la France comment ne
pas se sentir à patrie décrivez-vous sur
sa propre terre
moi j'aime l'Amérique je suis pas
anti-américain l'anti-américanisme comme
dit l'historien Jacques juliart c'est le
socialisme des imbéciles donc je suis
pas du tout entier américain c'est idiot
de parler comme ça mais en même temps le
fait que l'Amérique nous ait vendu tout
ça c'est à dire par exemple je parlais
tout à l'heure du walkisme c'est à dire
ou du décolinialisme ou du d'espèces de
racialisme vous voyez que qui qui
envahit la société française et qui est
proprement débile et le fait que par
exemple des faits divers aux États-Unis
je pense par exemple à faire genre je
Floyd qui est une histoire affreuse mais
on dit immédiatement ça vient en France
et on a l'impression que ça s'est
déroulé en France et les gens donc ça ce
phénomène là je déteste ça parce que il
y a une spécificité française il y a une
spécificité française et ça il faut la
garder et pour ça moi je suis
effectivement je reviens à ce que penser
mon père
les centres commerciaux la grande
distribution tout ça non il faut revenir
sur la France vous voyez les bistrots
les boulangers
la danse aujourd'hui à ce point bien sûr
bien sûr avec l'idée que tout ça c'est
de toute façon il faut tout refaire tout
repenser voilà et ça non ça c'est c'est
vraiment franchement je pense qu'il faut
lutter contre ça et c'est vrai que moi
dans dans quand j'entends ça je je peux
pas m'empêcher de ma mère
je m'en fiche et puis je m'en fiche de
ce qu'on dit vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est ce que je ressens et
franchement je sais que je suis pas tout
seul je sais que je suis pas tout seul
et vous savez on s'en sortira en se
battant et en étant fier de nous et puis
après évidemment on accueillant les
autres moi je tends toujours la main
j'ai pas non vous restez avec moi France
on va accueillir nos chroniqueurs nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris la Belle
Époque vous avez compris c'est
absolument captivant c'est jubilatoire
les chapitres sont vifs enlevés très
courts et on revisite la cinquième la
connaissent pas vous avez bossé ouvert
vos carnets et
une série de correspondances que vous
avez que vous avez retrouvé des
témoignages inédits également merci vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure donc
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix ce soir Marco pommier va
nous parler du système D de ses députés
enceintes à l'Assemblée nationale ce
sera son histoire du jour le scandale
des placardisés avec Fanny guinochet et
puis le regard d'Isabelle Lasserre sur
les premiers aveu de faiblesses de
Vladimir Poutine sur l'état de l'armée
russe nos affranchies les voici bonsoir
à vous trois bonsoir Marco pommier on va
commencer avec vous vous parlez vous
oubliez et es de l'Assemblée nationale
ces femmes députés qui tombent enceinte
et partent en congé maternité
l'assemblée n'a jamais prévu ce cas de
figure Myriam je ne suis pas forcément
le mieux placé pour vous parler de ce
sujet je suis un homme jeune et sans
enfant mais enfin quand même le sujet
parait un peu
ubuesque en 2022 aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes une députée enceinte rien n'est
prévu dans le règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale résultat ces femmes laissent
généralement leur siège vacants le temps
d'accoucher c'est le cas d'Aurore berger
président du groupe Renaissance
vous attendez un bébé c'est la semaine
prochaine que vous vous arrêtez
normalement ben écoutez parce que pour
le coup ça c'est vraiment des moments de
grâce
voilà Aurore berger qui va se retirer de
l'Assemblée dès ce vendredi mais pas de
reconnaissance pour elle de son congé
maternité car député c'est un mandat et
pas un métier dont vous n'avez pas les
mêmes droits Aurore Bagé pourra quand
même voter des textes un vote par
délégation mais uniquement pour les
scrutins publics dans l'hémicycle il
n'empêche que la situation est un peu
cocasse c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui
a voté le congé maternité qui a voté le
congé paternité aussi mais il ne
s'applique pas à ses propres élus et le
cas d'horreur Robert je n'ai pas isolé à
l'Assemblée oui même cas de figure pour
Marie le bec la députée Renaissance
attend son deuxième enfant c'est pour
début 2023 pour elle pas facile de
s'éclipser en politique pendant
plusieurs semaines mais attention à ne
pas culpabiliser
parfois on a cette image un peu de a une
femme enceinte c'est quelqu'un qui va
être moins disponible etc or moi je
crois que voilà c'est pas forcément un
frein à une carrière professionnelle un
engagement quel qu'il soit le tout c'est
de trouver
un équilibre personnel il y aura une
solution ce serait de demander au
suppléant de la député de le remplacer
oui mais pour l'instant c'est impossible
Myriam ce n'est pas prévu par la
Constitution du coup pour remédier à
cette situation Mathilde ignié de la
France insoumise et fraîchement à
déposer une proposition de loi pour
permettre aux députés qui deviennent
parents de se faire remplacer par leur
suppléant une proposition de loi qui
doit encore mûrir pour poser les
conditions du remplacement parce qu'en
pratique aujourd'hui les suppléant ne
peuvent pas aller à l'Assemblée alors
ils essayent d'aider comme ils peuvent
écouter justement le suppléant de
Mathilde
j'arrive à me libérer de temps en temps
en fonction des obligations pardon
personnel pour aller la représenter sur
des événements en local pour montrer que
bah oui elle est elle est encore
présente j'essaie de la remplacer en
fonction des disponibilités du travail
parce que bon je suis aujourd'hui à mon
compte je fais des marchés genre du pain
donc il faut fabriquer le pain il faut
pouvoir aller sur le marché après ou
faire remplacer c'est très très très
compliqué voilà Myriam pour l'instant la
proposition de la France insoumise n'a
pas encore été inscrite à l'ordre du
jour alors à quand le changement les
règles d'aujourd'hui ont été conçues par
des hommes pour des hommes maintenant
l'assemblée c'est féminisée seulement
12% de femmes dans l'hémicycle en 2002
c'est 37% aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Marco ça semble insensé et vous étiez
parfaitement qualifié pour nous parler
de ce sujet
maternité quand même alors oui c'est
vrai aussi un vrai sujet il faudrait
l'intégrer aucune règle prévue quand
même parce que en avait une Assemblée
nationale totalement machiste avec que
des hommes aujourd'hui maintenant on
découvre les femmes ça évidemment il y a
ces problèmes
j'espère parce que supplément l'art du
compromis peut-être qu'il sera voilà au
rendez-vous Fanny journaliste économique
à France Info bien sûr vous nous parlez
ce soir des fameux placards dans les
entreprises il y a une étude qui s'est
penchée sur ce j'ai complètement tabou
c'est l'Institut Montaigne il y aurait
200000 personnes placardisées en France
effectivement c'est le calcul que fait
ce cercle de réflexion libérale et c'est
un sujet vous l'avez dit tabou quelque
chose que personne ne veut voir alors
être placard disait c'est être maintenu
dans son poste être payé à ne rien faire
être exclu du collectif on n'est plus
invité aux réunions vous devenez
transparent c'est évidemment humiliant
dégradants et plutôt que de vous
licencier et bien l'entreprise joue la
montre elle attend que vous par
lassitude par découragement par éco Man
et bien finalement elle vous maintient
dans vos fonctions et elle attend qu'à
un moment vous claquez la porte par
dépit en catimini c'est évidemment
contraire au Code du travail ça peut
être assimilé à du harcèlement moral
mais faut-il encore pouvoir le prouver
le démontrer et c'est évaluation de 200
000 personnes qui sont concernées
aujourd'hui en France elle se base en
fait sur une étude sur la base d'un
sondage d'une étude cantar donc si ça se
trouve c'est même plus dit l'Institut
Montaigne évidemment ça coûte cher et ça
coûte cher au contribuable la société
effectivement il y a un coût moral
humain financier 10 milliards d'euros ce
sont les évaluations milliards d'euros
voilà c'est gigantesque 10 milliards
d'euros c'est toujours le chiffre par
exemple qu'on avance en disant c'est ce
qu'il faudrait pour régler la question
du grand âge c'est une bonne partie
aussi du déficit des retraites qui
pourraient être réglées avec ce sujet
parce que c'est de la productivité
finalement qui est perdue alors comme on
arrive à une telle somme et bien il faut
prendre en compte les salaires versés
mais aussi tout ce que ça coûte à
l'assurance maladie parce que ce sont
souvent en se met en arrêt quand on est
placardisé sont souvent des arrêts très
long on prend des médicaments il y a de
la dépression il y a un coût
psychologique qui est très lourd que
paie le contribuable alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire une solution pour des
placards d'idées voilà l'Institut
montagne préconise déjà de faire un état
des lieux un vrai officiel avec des DRH
des syndicats des syndicalistes des
médecins du travail pour essayer de
d'évaluer un peu plus finement le
problème l'idée aussi c'est de faire de
la prévention auprès des managers pour
éviter que ces placards continuent parce
que souvent d'ailleurs ça touche les
plus fragiles ça touche plus les femmes
que les hommes ça touche plus les
seniors en fin de carrière que les
jeunes alors on peut regretter qu'il n'y
ait pas dans les préconisations de cette
institut de ce rapport des sanctions ou
même des pénalités et puis après il y a
quelque chose de très simple ça reste un
problème culturel donc en parler ne pas
baisser les yeux c'est un peu comme la
discrimination c'est déjà peut-être
faire changer les choses à faire bouger
les choses les mentalités le scandale
des placardisés vous en avez ta carte
d'idée des journalistes allez sans
langue de bois quand vous étiez patron
du point ou de l'autre en général à
ouvrir les placards et régler les
problèmes j'ai eu problème mais j'étais
toujours été ma tendance parce que je
trouve ça effectivement vous avez raison
sur le côté très humiliant et très
souvent ce sont des comment dire des des
réactions paresses de manager dans des
entreprises qui gagnent de l'argent et
qui font qui reporte des problèmes
souvent les collectivités
ça on connaît tous des cas des cas
autour de nous mais ça justement je
pense que il faut quand même parler en
parler et puis c'est comme ça qu'on
réglera le problème mais en même temps
il y a des problèmes aussi légaux
c'est-à-dire on voit très bien que ce
sont des bras de fer la plupart du temps
sur des le montant d'indemnité et qui
dure et qui dure et qui dure et il faut
peut-être à un moment donné qu'on fixe
non qu'on fixe des règles à un moment
donné voilà le coup préton quoi vous
connaissez évidemment Isabelle
évidemment je connais qu'elle
dit Figaro grand je crois que c'est le
seul homme décision que j'ai prise de ma
vie non coup de tonnerre au Kremlin hier
isab pour la première fois depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre Vladimir
Poutine a reconnu que son armée n'était
pas suffisamment opérationnel oui Myriam
c'était à l'occasion de la de la
première réunion du nouveau conseil de
coordination qu'il a créé la semaine
dernière et dont l'objectif est de
rendre un petit peu la guerre plus
efficace alors le président russe vous
devriez le voir sur ces images qui se
voit pendant la réunion oui a reconnu ce
qu'il appelle des difficultés
administratives et économiques liées aux
sanctions Vladimir Poutine je cite
encore promet d'accélérer le processus
décisionnaire dans la campagne
ukrainienne il veut aussi renforcer la
coordination des structures
gouvernementales et régionales traduite
en langage français on va dire quoi ces
mesures sont destinées à réorganiser
l'armée qui rencontre des problèmes de
logistique d'équipements de motivation
elle soit aussi un langlissement vers
une économie de guerre qui exige de plus
en plus des services des des
secteur industriel et des services qui
se mettent au utilise justement de
l'opération en Ukraine est-ce que les
sanctions européennes occidentales elles
expliquent les difficultés de l'armée
russe alors en partie oui parce qu'elles
ont mis très longtemps à être efficaces
mais là on sent vraiment leurs effets
notamment l'armée russe n'arrive plus à
se procurer les pièces de rechange des
équipements mais évidemment il y a
beaucoup d'autres raisons qui expliquent
le recul spectaculaire des forces russes
face à la contrefensive de l'armée
ukrainienne d'abord les armées la
dispersion des différentes armées alors
les hommes de de Kadir of le Tchétchène
les forces régulières les combattants de
Wagner toutes ces armées sont
complètement dispersées elles ne
communiquent pas entre elles et un
déficit de sous-officier ça c'est très
connu puis il y a aussi bien entendu un
manque de volonté des soldats qui savent
pas pourquoi ils se battent et on sait
tous que dans une guerre l'un des nerfs
de la guerre c'est la force morale bien
sûr r pourquoi faut-il faire ça pourquoi
Poutine parle-t-il publiquement parce
qu'ils doivent répondre à sa population
et assez militaire parce que l'aile RA
du pouvoir ne ménage plus ses critiques
assez violentes d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de
Vladimir Poutine sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur les blogs et la gitechen aussi
qu'a dit Rohff considère que la réponse
de Vladimir Poutine est trop faible
c'est quand même pas mal lui aimerait
que les villes soient carrément rayées
de la carte de la carte du crâne la
population aussi commence à grincer des
dents parce que les femmes et les maires
de soldats qui sont envoyés sur le front
sont obligés d'envoyer des équipements
parce qu'ils sont envoyés sans bottes
sans manteau sans rien quelquefois alors
il est peu probable évidemment que la
machine se dégrippe assez rapidement
Vladimir Poutine le sait et c'est
d'ailleurs sans doute pour ça
aujourd'hui qu'il a annoncé
l'organisation d'exercices nucléaires il
est allé sur les bases surveillées de
routine voilà histoire de bien faire
montrer
pas aussi vite qu'il j'espère prendre
Olivier vous le croyez capable de
l'utiliser cette arme nucléaire ou pas
Isabelle Lasserre on a la chance d'avoir
vraiment l'une des meilleures
spécialistes qui s'est très confiée par
rapport à d'autres non vraiment bravo
chapeau donc moi je bois ses parents et
je préfère lui poser des questions de
commentaires est-ce que vous diriez
quand même que sur sur Poutine il y a eu
un peu un aveuglement notre pays
on s'interroge sur la France aujourd'hui
je suis désolé on en parlait tout à
l'heure l'état de la France aujourd'hui
qu'on vous dit le nombre de petits de
lettres il faut quand même être un
abruti ou un personnage abject et
cynique pour être encore Poutine ou
l'autre aujourd'hui et on envoie on
envoie notamment aux deux extrêmes
aujourd'hui les filles comme JRM ils
sont planqués bien entendu mais une
demande qui a ressurgir d'ailleurs ils
disent toujours ah non mais faut pas
aider trop l'Ukraine il faut pas aider
l'Ukraine c'est vrai on sent très bien
que ils sont prêts à repartir là-dedans
c'est-à-dire la fascination en France il
faut bien dire on l'a vu dans les années
40 du mal de l'abjection de de la
terreur moi franchement c'est Macron sur
ce dossier il est bien
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire d'autre
on n'a pas d'armée on fait peur à
personne enfin on a pas d'armée il y a
pas d'armée européenne il y a pas de
défense européenne on a une petite armée
française mais de toute façon qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire donc il essaye ouais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre de
toute façon c'est de ce point de vue ça
nous dépasse complètement et ce qui est
extraordinaire et ce qui est fascinant
c'est justement on parlait tout à
l'heure fier d'être français bah il y a
des gens aussi qui sont fiers des trucs
très bien et vous avez plus personne ne
peut douter aujourd'hui pour les siècles
à venir qui a une nation
ukrainienne ça a été nié pendant
longtemps ça d'ailleurs les rues se
mêlent d'ailleurs de parfois on a le
sentiment qu'ils ont visité le nier
aussi pour la Pologne mais c'est parce
qu'ils ont contrôlé ces pays pendant
deux siècles mais non elle est là voilà
la nation elle est là on va s'arrêter là
la nation ukrainienne sous nos yeux qui
se battent d'une certaine manière pour
nous aussi européen merci les affranchis
merci Franz Olivier Gilbert évidemment
vous l'avez compris au Conseil la belle
époque c'est Gallimard à demain même
heure
[Musique]